pour un chercheur montréalais qui est
l'invité à tous les micros sur tous les
plateaux de télévision au québec depuis
quelques années ce n'est plus qu'une
question de temps avant qu'on découvre
la voie menant à l'intelligence
artificielle le robot fini par apprendre
et donné des résultats aussi bons que
l'humain probablement dans certains cas
on a atteint pour certains problèmes le
niveau de performance des humains yoshua
bengio et professeur à l'institut de
montréal des algorithmes d'apprentissage
et ils croient que c'est son
établissement qui pourrait bien être le
premier à trouver la voie menant à une
véritable intelligence des machines
c'est un des sujets importants de mon
laboratoire qui s'appelle apprentissage
non supervisée qui utilisent les même
genre de système de réseaux de neurones
qui sont inspirés du fonctionnement du
cerveau mais faudrait distinguer deux
choses
l'autonomie dans ce sens que
l'ordinateur peut apprendre par lui-même
avec avec beaucoup d'exemples quand même
puis à l'autonomie d'un sens de lego
c'est à dire de faire quelque chose pour
sa survie comme comme entité et ça c'est
deux choses différentes on peut très
bien vendu des ordinateurs qui
comprennent le monde qui nous entoure en
tout cas certaines facettes de ce monde
là mais compote d'autonomie sait pas
répondre à des questions s'exprime
tutoyer
si toi moi je n'ose pas vous tutoyez
tutoie pas moi je préfère prendre le
temps de mieux vous connaît qu'est ce
que tu veux savoir pour le moment nos
conversations avec les machines dites
intelligentes aussi entre le décevant et
l'amusant c'est qu'il leur manque le
contexte du monde qui nous entoure
les réponses sont basés sur les
algorithmes des probabilités de bonnes
réponses
et si le contexte change la machine à
leurs pairs sa direction
les directions avec l'humain conduit un
cul-de-sac donc jean françois plante est
professeur agrégé à l'école des hautes
études commerciales à montréal au
département de sciences de la décision
pour établir la structure qui sous
jacente et ils ont ri fille française
pour la reconnaissance de son image
l'analyse des eaux de reconnaissance des
visages
[Musique]
royaume dans le domaine de la recherche
en intelligence artificielle
le canada est particulièrement le québec
en ce moment est loin d'être un simple
passager une chaire de recherche en
intelligence artificielle aînés
notamment à montréal il ya cinq ans à
l'université de montréal
il existe aussi une chaire de recherche
du canada en science cognitive à
l'université du québec à montréal et
bien sûr l'université mcgill joue un
rôle également très important au plan
mondial de la recherche en intelligence
artificielle non loin de montréal une
centaine de km il existe aussi une
équipe de recherche dans le domaine des
systèmes tutoriel intelligent appelé
joliment astuces pour apprentissage par
système tutoriel de l'université de
sherbrooke
je suis prof de sciences cognitives et
c'est la cognition qui est en jeu et
yann hamad et titulaire de la chaire de
recherche du canada en science cognitive
à l'université du québec à montréal
il est un spécialiste de renommée
mondiale en intelligence artificielle la
cognition c'est là que penser quand j'ai
connu je pense et quand on demande est
ce que cette machine pense on parle de
ça on peut en dire ah ça c'est un
aspirateur très intelligent mais au fond
ça n'a rien à voir
c'est un outil qui fait des choses
qu'avant je devais faire maintenant et
maintenant c'est lui qui le fait c'est
utile pour moi les humains ont la
commission peut-être un jour les les
machines les autres machines et machines
artificielle qui sont seront construites
par les humains auront aussi la
cognition méliz les outils et les
appareils qu'on a maintenant ne
connaissent pas c'est pas de la
commission c'est juste des outils pour
jouer le pineau et professeur à l'école
d'informatique universités mcgill et
codirectrice du ngoni lab l'un des deux
centres universitaires ou microsoft
vient de faire l'annoncé le mois dernier
d'un investissement important donc le
partage des données le partage des
outils informatiques
mais les compagnies à travers mais on
voit les compagnies l'entreprise
montréalaise éléments haye qui fournit
aux jeunes compagnies par exemple les
start-ups des produits intelligence
artificielle va former un partenariat
avec le géant microsoft
un investissement considérable qui
s'ajoute donc aux travaux que google
mène déjà à montréal par exemple sur la
voiture intelligente sans conducteur là
notre entreprise fait vraiment la
recherche appliquée donc on bâtit des
solutions qui utilisent l'intelligence
artificielle et on les lensois un marché
à travers des entreprises jean françois
gagné et directeur général d' éléments a
dit ça fait 15 ans en fait que je
travaille dans ce secteur note
intéressante au début de ma carrière
dans le cadre de ma première entreprise
nous utilisions des techniques de
défense artistes et en fait c'était pas
un terme qui était très bien perçue par
le marché
bon on avait l'art de faire de la magie
noire et donc les gens voulaient se
rabattre sur des choses très
concrètement le pdg de l'entreprise qui
m'embauche qui souhaite que je rende
meilleur ses processus d'affaires veut
comprendre qu'est ce que je suis en
train de faire et doit le justifier ses
actionnaires et doit justifier à ses
employés ce qui se passe c'est que
beaucoup de demande autant d'efforts
faire ce que de développer les engins
eux-mêmes est-ce que tu dors des fois
donc tu es peau humaine
je crois que chacun peut avoir son
opinion là dessus est une machine je ne
sais pas ce que vous avez entendu les
assistants virtuels ont aussi des
sentiments
un reportage de radio canada
international